hey what's up guys my name is echano
welcome back to another hazel
development log is anyone else as
excited as i am right now
so last time we had one of these we were
basically in the middle of vulcan week i
think i just wrapped up vulcan week
and i didn't want to share too many of
my thoughts regarding vulcan at that
point because of course
i was exhausted from the entire week of
just non-stop balcony
huh falconing we should get that on the
sweatshirt except
maybe not now whilst welcome week may be
over and i mean we're not completely
done with vulcan yet there's still quite
a lot of things that i want to do and
we'll continue to do
throughout live streams in the next
coming few weeks i don't really want to
spend today talking too much about
vulcan itself i want to actually wait
until i've
pretty much finished that and actually
gotten to the point where i can do
everything
using the vulcan renderer that i used to
be able to do in the opengl renderer and
then we'll talk about
vulcan in a little bit more detail what
i wanted to talk about today was just
the concept
of longer term planning so in other
words not just
writing a quick little to-do list of
things that you're going to get done
today or this week
but just having a general sense of
direction and
my opinions about the importance of
having something like that
i've always been a person to set
long-term goals
and have fairly ambitious ideas in my
mind i've never really liked the idea of
okay let's just let's just focus on this
week let's take it one step at a time
i never really like that which of course
has its own downsides it's very
important to be able to do stuff in the
short term
my mind has always been kind of floating
in the longer term you know
what are we going to be able to do with
this why are we doing this
where are we heading towards what are we
going to do with our lives that kind of
existential stuff and so because my mind
kind of works a little bit more like
that or maybe he's inclined to think
about that a lot more than
one might say is healthy it's important
for me to consider
what we're doing in the grand scheme of
things and not just what we're focusing
on one step at a time and that's what
we're going to be talking about today
but first i want to mention
that this video is sponsored by
skillshare for those of you who still
don't know what skillshare is and you
haven't tried it out for yourselves
skillshare is an amazing online learning
community where millions of creative and
curious people from all around the world
can come together into one spot to learn
a new skill basically it's a platform
with a whole bunch of amazing bite-sized
video courses on various things so
whether you're interested in learning
more about
photography videography how to market
the product you're working on general
business stuff art and illustration
other creative topics
music productivity skillshare has got
you covered now i don't know what kind
of situation you guys are in of course
but where i live we're in the middle of
quite a serious lockdown right now and
so
there really isn't much to do and one of
the things that i've been noticing is
that the less productive i am and the
more i just slack off and don't really
do anything with my life
the worse i feel there's only so much
entertainment you can kind of fill
yourself with before you just
begin to feel empty and you need
something a little bit more meaningful
to do with your time or
at least i do i think pouring some of
your time into productivity into
something creative maybe picking up an
illustration class on skillshare or
something like that
is a really good way to make sure that
you're still mentally
taking care of yourself coming in at
just under 10 dollars a month for an
annual subscription skillshare is a
great place to do that but of course
skillshare is giving you guys a free
trial for a limited time so definitely
click the link in the description below
to check it out
i think it's a really good way to spend
some of your time as i mentioned
planning something long term
is kind of important for me it might not
be important for you
everyone works differently which is why
my number one advice most of the time is
do what works for you this of course is
more of like a
personal vlog i guess where i talk about
obviously what's working for me and all
the progress i'm making
so take everything i say with a grain of
salt as usual
it's just my opinion working on larger
projects like a game engine as i
mentioned before it's very easy to
actually get overwhelmed
and if you just sit down at your desk on
monday morning and you think
okay what am i gonna work on this week i
have no idea let's
let's take a look at all of the various
features i could jam into my game engine
you will probably feel pretty bad by the
end of that the reason being there's an
infinite amount of stuff that you could
shove into a game engine i mean look at
unreal and unity
they're still building their technology
and they have like thousands of people
because of that i thought one of the
best things that i could actually do for
myself was to sit down
think about the near future meaning the
next quarter maybe until the end of the
year that kind of time frame
and actually think about manageable
chunks of work that i can complete in
that time
that will actually fulfill some kind of
goal so in other words i thought that
the work that i would do in that time
frame would need to be working towards
some kind of
feature or goal that would actually make
hazel
essentially more usable or take it to
the next level for example one of my
goals with vulcan and why i wanted to
actually implement vulcan in the first
place was apart from the fact that i
wanted to rewrite the renderer and make
it a little bit more capable
i also really want to get real-time ray
tracing into hazel
before the end of the year now whilst
that's something that i would probably
be working on right now if i could i
also have to consider
what the game engine needs because i am
a team of one essentially there are
quite a lot of people in the community
helping out
nowadays which is amazing of course but
i still need to consider
you know this is not just kind of my
little passion project that i'm working
on
on the side like this needs to progress
into a game engine there's a significant
amount of people
who are investing in this and who are
actually you know paying attention to
this and i don't want to just
work on whatever i feel like because i
don't feel very responsible doing that
and we're not going to get to the point
where we can actually start using hazel
very quickly if i spend all of my time
doing just various graphics things like
rage racing
that of course are fairly low priority
in the grand scheme of things
so because of that i went back to the
sun and i thought about what a game
engine
kind of is and what's needed to actually
make it usable
in a similar way to how you would
perhaps build a very advanced and
complicated programming api
going to the end and working backwards
is kind of helpful so in other words
let's think about what game we want to
make with hazel something simple
and what i decided to do was some kind
of simple mario clone maybe with some
extra features maybe it's not exactly
the same as mario and game mechanics or
anything
but it should look kind of similar to
mario maybe it's like a 2d platformer
maybe we extend it in certain ways but
that's the basic idea so to make
something like mario like the original
1985
mario what do we need to put into hazel
is it possible for us to make it right
now
well no okay why not what do we need to
be able to create mario
in hazel and of course i am talking
about hazel dev specifically which has
like the full level editor and like the
the play
the play and stop of the scene and like
all the c sharp scripting all of that
stuff so
what does that need to actually make it
possible to
make a game like mario and so i sat down
on live stream actually twitter tv
channel is where i usually stream i sat
down on the live stream with a bunch of
you guys as well and i
just talked about what we would need to
make that happen and i put all of that
down into a road map onto trello now
i'll leave a link in the description
below to the roadmap that you're
currently seeing on the screen but this
is just hazel engine.com
roadmap this is the roadmap for the
development version of hazel which is
available to patrons
putting together this kind of list of
features that i would do one after the
other
makes developing hazel a lot easier
because i don't have to sit down and
think about what i need i've already
done that i can just sit down and start
working
on whatever it is it's kind of like
going to the gym in a way
if you can just get yourself to the gym
you sit down at a piece of equipment and
you start
actually doing the work you don't need
to think about it you just do the work
you just shut up and do it
even if you don't want to because you
know that this is in your plan or
you're already there you're doing it i
think it's very similar in this regard
you can sit down arbitrarily and
program anything you want and get
nowhere but if you know that okay i have
to do this i'm not doing anything else
but this because this is the step that
i'm currently on
i think the work just flows a little bit
more easy because you don't need to
think about like oh why am i even doing
this
you know why you're doing this you're
doing this because you're working
towards a particular goal
this needs to be done you can't get
there before you finish this so clearly
let's just shut up and get this done
stop complaining you'll also note in the
roadmap there are some sections for
electron diffuser and peter
as well these are two lovely people from
the community who have actually just
decided to contribute to hazel because
there are more and more people
asking to contribute to hazeldev i've
decided to make some kind of like
community roadmap as well so that people
can see what other people are working on
because there's been situations where
two people have
basically worked on the same feature and
then whoever finishes it first
gets to merge it in and then the other
person is just like well that was a bit
of a waste of time
so to avoid that i just want to be a
little bit more transparent with what
everyone's working on so if someone
comes along and says hey i want to work
on this
then we can actually see if anyone else
is working on that and they don't have
to worry about
about potentially stepping on someone
else's work
more on that kind of community stuff
later now i also made a
bit of a road map for the game engine
series for that version of hazel that's
just
a link link to that as well but it's
hazel engine.com roadmap that is more or
less a roadmap of the actual game engine
series on youtube
so i also thought it would be of course
a good idea to sit down and think about
what we're working towards
for that it's very similar to the stuff
that we're doing in hazel dev we're just
doing it in hazel dev because i actually
want to put together a game properly
using like c sharp scripting and
everything
but it is also the next logical step for
the game engine series i've decided to
put a lot more of my
effort towards just basically developing
this stuff in hazel dev as quickly as i
can
and then the game engine series is just
going to be me essentially taking code
from hazeldev
rewriting it live on stream live on the
video and then explaining everything
that i'm doing and
why i think it's going to clear my mind
a little bit more for developing this
game engine series because i already
know exactly the code that's
been written because it's been written
in hazel dev especially because
this kind of stuff in hazeldev we might
as well just take that kind of more test
and more ready code
and put that into the game engine series
just straight away i also think that
it's important to not be too harsh with
deadlines on yourself i mean
i'm taking this stuff seriously
obviously and if i was potentially
working like in a game studio or
something
like that of course there would be
deadlines my manager would expect me to
finish this
like in the next sprint or in the next
couple weeks or whatever
but i think it's kind of unrealistic to
try and run myself
as if i am working for a game studio or
for a professional company because
i mean the fact of the matter is i'm not
and so if i
start playing pretend i feel like i'll
just end up being a little bit more
stressed
and i have tried that before i've tried
working like nine to five or whatever
and
you know actually have deadlines and
pretend that i am at a real job but
i just i don't just don't think it makes
me happy and i don't think i end up
being as productive
if i'm kind of forcing myself into that
schedule one of the reasons i left
ea was because i didn't want to work
nine to five i wanted to do more with my
life and of course
this current lockdown is preventing a
whole bunch of that but i still think
it's important to try and work out a
work schedule
that works for you because at the end of
the day
if you're going to be more happy doing
the work that you're doing
you're going to produce better quality
work and you'll be more likely to work
more often and
for someone like me i think that's very
important to make sure that i'm mentally
in the right place because if i'm not
there's not much stopping me from just
being like
i'm not gonna work today i've got no
boss
anyway those are kind of the plans i
guess for hazel dev and the game engine
series check out those road maps
in the description below i did make a
specific uh section for
comments as well especially in the game
engine series hazel road map
so if you have any like concerns or if
you think this roadmap is rubbish then
you can actually comment right on trello
and leave it there as well but obviously
i'll read the comments for this video
below as well if you're interested in
grabbing the source code to hazeldev or
checking out all of the
past backlog of hazelden live streams
check out patreon.com the channels the
best way to help support me
and support hazel and this whole game
engine series project thank you to all
of you amazing patrons
for your support there's so much amazing
stuff coming in the future that i'm
super excited for
i will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you